I have some fascinating video to dig
into today Donald Trump has been having
trouble on the issue of race lately
Donald Trump's reaction to huge national
protests against police brutality after
George Floyd was killed by police was to
say send in more force and have the
military dominate the protesters that
was the word he used last week or the
week before on a call with governors so
it's obviously not going well for Trump
on race Donald Trump is polling 8% with
black voters eight eight percent
according to a new CNN poll so someone
got the bright idea let's send Trump to
be interviewed on Fox News but not by
one of their ubiquitous white blond
anchors have black woman Harris Falkner
interview Donald Trump this is going to
be great it's going to help him with
with black voters
it was absolutely and utterly insane and
I want to look at some clips with you
today
here's Trump pulling out the
cringe-worthy claim about him doing more
for black people than any other
president and he weirdly says let's not
include Lincoln in that although he adds
it is questionable how much Abraham
Lincoln really did for black people to
which even Fox News anchor harris
faulkner has to say well we are free mr.
president like Lincoln freed the slaves
you've done more for us to check out
this first clip and strap in folks
because it's gonna be wild it's just in
general I mean the economy is the great
unifier right now I think I've done more
for the black community than any other
president and let's take a pass on
Abraham Lincoln because he did good
although it's always questionable you
know in other words the entry so we are
free mr. president but we don't take a
pass at a Honest Abe as we call you say
you absolutely bizarre this is the
president talking like this and he
doesn't even have the historical
understanding to be able to recognize
how cringy this is like its total cringe
but he doesn't get it because he lacks
historical knowledge Trump who has
defended Confederate monuments says he's
done more for black people than any
other president so then we get into the
meat of it as it were related to the
protests
Donald Trump says and this really
requires some deep thinking to know what
on earth is this guy talking about
Trump says that police chokehold as a
concept are innocent and perfect
innocent and perfect and then he totally
dissembles into nonsense yeah and I
think the concept of choke all sounds so
innocent so perfect and then you realize
if it's a one-on-one now if it's
two-on-one that's a little bit of a
different story depending depending on
the toughness and strength you know
we're talking about toughness and
strength we are talking there's a
physical thing here also but if a police
officer is in a bad scuffle and he's got
somebody have to be careful what is he
talking about I'm not I'm not asking
rhetorically what is he talking about
now understand that there are lots of
Republicans who will say only 8% of
black voters support Trump because
they've been somehow tricked by
Democrats or they've fallen for
something which implicitly suggests
black voters are dumb that they they've
been tricked by Democrats watch this
interview and you understand why Trump
is polling 8% with black voters here's
more about chokeholds Trump saying
sometimes bad people something-something
chokeholds are good that's I mean I have
a hard time making more sense out of it
than that say no I don't want to see
mistakes yeah I don't like Joe calls now
I will say this as somebody that you
know you grow up and you wrestle and you
fight and you this before you see what
happens sometimes if you're alone and
you're fighting somebody's tough and you
get somebody in a chokehold what are you
gonna do say oh and it's a real bad
person and you know that and they do
exist I mean we have some real bad
people you saw that during the last
couple of weeks you saw some very good
people protesting do you saw some bad
people also and you get somebody in a
chokehold and what are you gonna do now
let go and say oh let's start all over
again I'm not allowed to have you in a
chokehold it's a tough situation now if
you have two people or another case and
the case that we're talking about two or
four people and two of them I guess just
pretty much started it's a very very
very tricky situation
so the chuckling is good because to talk
about because off the cuff it would
sound like absolutely but if you're
thinking about it then you realize maybe
there is a bad fight and the officer
gets somebody in a position I think you
have to probably see you want to be in
that conversation it's just not of this
world
there's there's nothing there there's no
substance there to even really analyze
another absolutely Looney Tunes moment
from this interview they get into the
phrase Trump used when the looting
starts the shooting starts Trump used
this phrase during the protests recently
the origins are a guy named Walter
Headley the police chief of Miami
Florida who said it in the 60s when
there was a violent of outbreak of crime
and it has a horribly racist history it
was positioned against the battle for
civil rights in the country at the time
and Trump was asked about the origins
and he kind of plays dumb he's like well
other people also said it like Philly
Police Commissioner Frank Rizzo used the
term now Rizzo did not actually use the
term but he did encourage brutal police
tactics and Trump just kind of says like
well Rizzo also said it which is not
technically true and then it gets just
really awkward if you if you have an
aversion to awkwardness I would maybe
skip the next two minutes me and and I'm
Paris on TV but I'm a black woman I'm a
mom and you know when and you've talked
about it but we haven't seen you come
out and be that consoler in this
instance and the tweets when the looting
starts the shooting starts why those
words so that's a an expression I've
heard over the years and Athena where I
used to I think Philadelphia the mayor
of Philadelphia the morning it comes
from 1967 I was about 18 months old at
the time everybody's shooting wiki
because they probably got it wrong but
it was from the chief of police in Miami
he was cracking down and he meant what
he said
and he said I don't even care if it
makes it look like brutality I'm gonna
down when the looting starts the
shooting stars that frightened a lot of
people when you you told that it also
comes from a very tough mayor who I
might have been police commissioner at
the time but I think mayor of
Philadelphia named Frank Rizzo and he
had an expression like that but I've
heard it many times so I think it's been
used many times it means two things
very different things one is if there's
looting there's probably going to be
shooting and that's not as a threat
that's really just a fact because that's
what happens and the other is if there's
looting there's going to be shooting
this is very they're very different
meanings Oh interesting
no there's very different meanings but I
think do you think most people see it
that way I think they see it both ways
no I mean I've had a view both ways I
think it's meant both ways can anybody
understand what he's talking about like
literally what is he saying I'm feeling
like my grammatical knowledge of English
is not up to par to properly parse what
Donald Trump is trying to say here so
let's now go backwards a little bit I'm
gonna go back to the start of the
interview with Harris Falkner and Trump
characterizes the protests really as
riots and unnecessary of course they
were mostly peaceful protests and they
were totally warranted given the
inaction on police brutality for so long
just completely dismissive Trump is of
the entire movement not exactly an
opportunity for a big coup with black
voters what's happened in the last
couple of weeks I feel like we are at
one of those historical moments where
future generations will look back and
they'll decide who we were are you the
president to unite all of us given
everything that's happening right now
well I certainly think so and I
certainly hope so and the relationships
we have are incredible the spirit of
this country and especially considering
what happened I mean we had out of
nowhere a plague come in from China he
just came in and it came to all over the
world it went all over the world you
looked at 186 countries and they were
devastated and we were certainly hit
very hard
some were hit harder than our own
we were hit very very hard and now we're
making our comeback and then on top of
it we had the the riots which were
unnecessary to the extent they were if
the governors and mayor's would have
taken a stronger action I think the
riots would have been you could call
them protesters you could call them riot
so different nights different things
says riots again says riots again says
you could call them protests but they're
really riots and then following up this
dismiss at dismissiveness with even more
remember they sat him in front of black
fox news anchor harris faulkner i guess
as part of the optics here and he just
says horrible things here trump says
lots of the protests that protesters
didn't even know why they were
protesting which is just completely
dismissive of the movement when he
called out mom on that tape it's a heart
punch so I'm curious from you what do
you think the protesters not not the
looters and the riders we're intelligent
enough to know the difference in our
country right what do you think they
want what do you think they need right
now from you so I think you'd protesters
for different reasons and then you had
protesting also because you know they
just didn't know I've watched i watch
you very closely why are you here and
they really weren't able to say but they
were there a reason perhaps but a lot of
them really were there because they
following the crowd a lot of them they
were there because what we witnessed was
a terrible thing what we saw was a
terrible thing and we've seen it over
the years we haven't you know this was
one horrible example but you've seen
other terrible examples you know that
better than anybody would would know it
yes black woman harris faulkner
would know better than anyone but again
protesters didn't know why they were
there according to Donald Trump so
listen you can find people who were out
there who were just trying to cause
trouble or going with the crowd but the
answer is the overwhelmingly peaceful
protests were there because of police
brutality you say that first not as an
aside or at the end completely
disastrous interview but two totally
with you I don't know that it matters
anybody who would be disgusted with this
interview is already not voting for
Donald Trump anybody who just watches
Fox News and gets in line and is
planning to vote for Trump is going to
vote for him anyway regardless of this
interview so we've got to hit that slice
who might change their minds and I don't
know that many of those folks are
actually going to see this interview
it's tragic it's sad because this is
really exposing the lack of critical
thinking and and sort of thoughtfulness
and introspection that Donald Trump
experiences a total lack of and it's you
know if you really sit down and listen
to each of his answers you understand
the guy understands nothing he just
knows nothing he doesn't even you know
he he's there for a particular reason
there's a reason that with what's going
on he's being interviewed by harris
faulkner and he still fails to keep it
together in the way that this type of
strategy would hope that he would be
able to do just absolutely insane we're
going to have more clips from this
interview on the david pakman show
Instagram which is at david pakman show
on my instagram david pakman you can see
me at a socially distanced outdoor cafe
over the weekend an incredible moment
just I just sat down outside somewhere
and it felt like a huge thing that's on
my Instagram David Pakman we'll take a
quick break and be back after this what
a crazy weekend it's good to be back and
there's so much to talk about we have a
big media story free speech story
censorship story actually it's really
just a media story advertisers are
fleeing Fox News propagandist Tucker
Carlson's program why because of
constantly racially charged and quite
frankly boring and predictable nonsense
that is totally toxic and right away the
whole I don't really understand the
First Amendment crowd is out in force
defending Tucker Carlson against second
I'm sorry First Amendment not Second
Amendment First Amendment
misunderstandings and so-called charges
of censorship but what we're actually
seeing is the marketplace of ideas that
these right-wingers claim
to want and I'm going to get to that a
little bit later after explaining to you
what took place being associated with
Tucker Carlson's program is bad for some
advertisers in the marketplace and they
are making the decision to bail so just
the other day Tucker Carlson said on his
show the protests aren't really about
black lives and that ominously they will
come for you it wasn't clear when he
said it if he meant black people or who
later claimed that he met Ono Democrats
I guess here's what he had to say this
may be a lot of things this moment we're
living through but it is definitely not
about black lives and remember that when
they come for you and at this rate they
will anyone's ever been subjected to the
rage of the mob knows the feeling it's
like being swarmed by Hornets you cannot
think clearly a bunch of companies that
had been advertising on Tucker Carlson's
program decided to pull their
advertising because of that and other
clips it wasn't just one thing
apparently
this includes Disney this includes Papa
John's Pizza which is historically a
horrible horrible company a t-mobile
Poshmark
and some other brands so in a second
we're going to talk about the free
speech and censorship component to this
because the misunderstandings that are
floating around are disturbing in terms
of the lack of understanding of anything
related to speech and censorship that
they that they portray but I want to be
really like extra super clear about
something here I said this is just
business and this is just business it's
a market decision that's being made by
these companies Papa John's said they
are deciding to stop all advertising on
opinion shows in general it's not that
they're particularly upset with what
Tucker said they're making a business
decision to pull advertising from all
opinion programs the other advertisers
are the Papa John's and other
advertisers they're not bailing on Fox
News there are there they're not saying
the problem is that Fox is so
harebrained that they allow Tucker
Carlson a platform to say this stuff
they're just moving from Tucker Carlson
to other fox news shows that are
under the microscope Fox News said that
these departures aren't causing a
financial hit because it's just moving
money from Tucker's show to other shows
so these are not political decisions in
general in the sense that these are
companies that are still okay sending
money to Fox News and they are okay with
Fox News carrying water in general for
Donald Trump and the terrible ideas
espoused by Donald Trump and and by the
network but they're not going to do it
on Tucker Carlson's show because it's
just become negative attention getter so
to speak so now that gets us to the
First Amendment free speech component
which for me is really the most
interesting thing a whole bunch of Trump
supporting right-wingers are saying this
is censorship of Tucker Carlson there's
a free speech violation First Amendment
you know fill in the blanks with your
generic censorship concern trolling
language and then let's debunk these
claims one by one first of all this has
nothing to do with the First Amendment
this is the participants here are
advertisers a TV channel and a TV host
and the audience First Amendment is not
a factor here the government is not
abridging anyone's speech whatsoever so
First Amendment into the trash out the
window second this is how capitalism in
the marketplace of ideas works
understand that there's no coercion
happening here there's you know the the
non-aggression principle people should
be pleased Tucker Carlson can choose I
guess he's allowed to say whatever he
wants on his program and that may have
repercussions Fox News is totally free
no coercion Fox News continues to employ
Tucker or not they may have a particular
contract with them where if they pull
them off the air they still gotta pay
them but they and Tucker Carlson agreed
on that contract with no government
intervention advertisers can choose to
advertise on any show they want or not
to for any reason they can say I don't
like the the suits that Tucker Carlson
wears or I don't like what Tucker
Carlson says they are free to decide
however they want to or not to advertise
on any particular program viewers like
you
can too
to watch or not watch tucker carlson
viewers can choose to contact
advertisers and say if you advertise
with tucker I will no longer buy your
stuff or they could say unless you
advertise with Tucker I won't buy your
stuff everybody's free to do whatever
they want period and interestingly the
advertiser can choose again
non-aggression no coercion if you're an
advertiser and people start writing to
you saying you'd better stop advertising
with Tucker or you'd better start
advertising with Tucker
either way the advertiser can choose to
listen to those people or not everybody
gets to make their choices now you're
going to hear some people pop up and
they are they're either ignorant or
their concern trolling and they will say
if you email a company and say I will
not buy your stuff if you do X or Y like
advertising with Tucker that's coercion
it's not coercion
it's called speech there's no violence
it's a marketplace this is literally
what the free marketeers claim to want I
as a buyer can choose to buy or not buy
a product for any reason that is
important to me I is a buyer and free to
tell a company why I am buying their
product or why I am not buying their
product and the company can choose
whether to pay attention to me or
whether to tell me to go to hell and do
whatever they want the company can
decide you know if we advertise with
Tucker we're gonna lose a thousand
customers but we might gain 2,000
because his audience is so big and that
extra thousand customers is worth it to
us despite the PR problem that it might
cause us to advertise with dr. Carlson
and they can decide whatever they want
the market is actually regulating itself
here without violence or government
intervention the right-wingers should be
cheering this but they're not they want
to frame it as a liberal mob trying to
hurt someone's ability to earn a living
we don't even know by the way whether
Tucker's income is affected by the
number of advertisers his show has it
may not be we don't know they are
pathetic and they are predictable and
they're so boring I mean
it's just it's getting so old that they
either don't understand or pretend not
to understand how markets and free
speech and censorship actually work okay
so earlier on the on in the show I told
you about the claims that John Bolton
makes in his book Donald Trump okaying
Chinese concentration camps Trump saying
invading Venezuela would be cool Trump
asking China for help getting reelected
Trump saying reporters should be
imprisoned or executed Trump didn't know
that the UK had nuclear weapons on and
on and on we did that earlier in the
show I then told you about the legal
battle by Trump's Justice Department to
suppress the publication of John
Bolton's book including a footnote
provision that is asking courts to ban
bookstores from selling Bolton's book
under threat of punishment or legal
action so we already did all of that
stuff now I want to talk about Donald
Trump's reaction Donald Trump
predictably
was so triggered by what is in John
Bolton's book that he absolutely
exploded both on television and on
Twitter it's been going for almost 24
hours now we just had to add more tweets
to this story because Trump just won't
stop tweeting so here is Trump kicking
it off last night with Sean Hannity Fox
News propagandists total total
disinformation whitewashing attempt of
of the entire story calling Bolton a
washed-up criminal let's take a look at
this clip and then in terms of Bolton he
broke the law he was a washed up guy I
gave him a chance
he couldn't get Senate confirmed so I
gave him an on Senate confirmed position
why could just put him there see how he
worked and I wasn't very enamored he
went into the Middle East he was one of
the the big guns were let's go into Iraq
and that didn't work out too well that I
was against that a long time ago before
I was ever even thinking about doing
what I'm doing now but he was one of the
people wanted to go direct when I asked
him about it I said recently I said you
know about a month in when he was about
a month in I said what do you think you
think you made a mistake there no I
don't think so I don't think so I said
explain that one so though
terrible terrible thing that he did but
he broke the law very simple I mean as
much as it's going to be broken this is
highly classified that's the highest
stage it's highly classified information
that he did not have approval so on this
is this is amazing
Trump says both that bolton's claims are
lies and that they're classified if
they're lies how are they classified its
made-up stuff right they do it just
doesn't make any sense and Trump's also
funny because he says Bolton was bad
because he went into Iraq and Trump
hired him 15 years later knowing that
doesn't Trump say he hires the best
people so Trump making no sense if it's
lies how are they classified if you hire
the best people why did you hire someone
that is so terrible and then the real
triggering Trump clearly sitting there
fermenting with his phone tweet after
embarrassing tweet and I want to look at
a couple of these with you Donald Trump
retweeting right-wing disinformation
propagator Dinesh D'Souza who attacked
bolton Donald Trump adding to D'Souza's
tweet President Bush fired him also
Bolton is incompetent Trump calling
Bolton a wacko and a dope tweeting quote
wacko but John Bolton's exceedingly
tedious book is made up of Lies and fake
stories said all good about me in print
until the day I fired him a disgruntled
boring fool who only wanted to go to war
never had a clue was ostracized and
happily dumped what a dope and I go back
again if they're lies how is it a
problem that Bolton is publishing
classified information if he's making it
all up it by definition couldn't be
classified because it doesn't really
exist right Trump kept going this
morning completely out of control saying
quote Bolton's book which is getting
terrible reviews is a compilation of
Lies and made-up stories all intended to
make me look bad many of the ridiculous
statements he attributes to me were
never made pure fiction just trying to
get even for firing him like the sick
pop
he is and again if it's all lies
why are you suppressing it on the basis
of it being classified and then a to
series to tweet series where he says
quote when whacko john bolton went on to
face the nation and so stupidly said
that he looked at the libyan model for
north korea all hell broke out kim
janghoon who we were getting along with
very well went ballistic just like his
missiles and rightfully so he didn't
want bolton anywhere near him
Bolton's dumbest of all statements set
us back very badly with north korea even
now i asked him what the hell were you
thinking he had no answer and just
apologized that was early on i should
have fired him right then and there now
we could do an hour on Trump with North
Korea and his delusions the real problem
with North Korea was Trump falling for
the same stuff that North Korean leaders
have been doing and saying for 30 years
Trump's actually believed it right other
presidents both Democrat and Republican
knew that they shouldn't fall for the
idiotic and unbelievable claims from
North Korean leaders Trump fell for them
so Trump thought he was making progress
so I mean I don't even know where where
to start all of this right Fox's
position has been to get experts on
saying Bolton's book in dangers our
national security by putting out
classified and secret information well
Trump says it's all lies so how can lies
be secret and classified at the same
time the real risk to our national
security all along has been Donald Trump
remember Trump once tweeted what should
have been a classified and remained
classified satellite photo national
security means nothing to Trump Trump
once had a meeting with Russians in the
Oval Office and shared Israeli
intelligence with them which he had not
been given the OK to share which
endangered an actual important source of
information about Isis for example which
Donald Trump claimed to be fighting very
very strongly about so if you want to
talk about endangering national security
and playing fast and loose with what
should be secret and classified
information
and I say should because I understand
legally Trump can declassify whatever he
wants
doesn't mean it's smart or prudent to do
it really it's Trump we need to be
looking at and again I I have a tweet
about this which you can look at I'm
Deepak meant on Twitter how is it that
Trump is furious that Bolton is both
lying but that what he writes in the
book is classified information if they
are lies it doesn't exist it's made up
and therefore being classified wouldn't
actually be a problem I'm sure that the
trumpets will find some way to excuse
that completely incoherent claim but it
is not making too much sense now let's
dig in I've been building to this Bolton
deserves huge criticism for what he did
to some degree and that's where we're
going to go next okay so in the last 24
hours the health questions about Donald
Trump have appeared not just on Fox News
as we already talked about but the
health questions around Trump has also
become a focus of a new ad from the
Republican pack Republican political
action committee called the Lincoln
project now we've talked about the
Lincoln project a little bit before it's
a pack run by some prominent Republicans
this includes George Conway who by the
way is the husband of Trump advisor
Kellyanne Conway a Steve Schmidt is part
of the Lincoln Project former McCain
campaign manager Rick Wilson and other
prominent Republicans they are a
Republican pack that realizes Trump is a
danger and must be removed their ads
have been going after Trump harder and
harder and yesterday they released an ad
that goes after Donald Trump on the
topic of his health again raising
questions about Trump's behavior over
the weekend at West Point linking
Trump's behavior to the last-minute
visit to Walter Reed Medical Center in
2019 so let's look at the ad let's
listen to the ad now some of these
elements are visual like for example
you'll hear voice over and they are
showing Donald Trump acting bizarrely so
I do recommend watching this online but
you'll get a sense of the story that's
being told from the narration let's take
a
something's wrong with Donald Trump he's
shaky weak trouble speaking trouble
walking so why are we talking about this
and why isn't the press covering Trump
secretive midnight run to Walter Reed
Medical Center why do so many reporters
who cover the White House pretend they
can't see Trump's decline the most
powerful office in the world needs more
than a week
unfit shaky president Trump doesn't have
the strength to lead nor the character
to admit it who are not doctors but
we're not blind it's time we talk about
this Trump is not well so this is really
quite well done even the details doubt
that down to the details it's very good
at one point when the voice-over says we
are not doctors what you see in the ad
is Trump's old dr. Harold Bornstein on
screen that's the guy that Donald Trump
allegedly coerced into writing that
bogus letter about how healthy Donald
Trump is so we are now seeing this I
guess we would call it a sort of hashtag
movement Trump is not well is the name
of it and it's going much more
mainstream than it ever has it's
happening thanks to right-wing media
it's happening thanks to a Republican
political action committee and to go
back to the analysis this is not about
Republicans are now going to be widely
concerned about Donald Trump's health
that's not going to happen the
importance of this is that there are
large swaths of the American population
that don't even know that there's been a
conversation about Trump's health
happening for three years there's large
portions of the electorate that have no
idea that dozens of medical experts both
from the Naropa neurology field and
mental health fields have been
expressing concern about Donald Trump's
health for years because they watch Fox
News and they only follow Republicans on
social media they don't know about
Trump's verbal glitches his wandering
off that time when he came off of Air
Force One his limo was right in front of
him he wandered off had to be brought
back by Secret Service losing his train
of thought sweating with the dilated
pupils while speaking upper Trump versus
downer Trump they don't know about it so
even hearing about this as a thing on
Fox News and through a Republican pack
is introducing it into their awareness
now 99% of them won't care but remember
that in 2016 the election came down to
75,000 votes in three states we will
mostly win if we get the turnout but
we'll take any help we can get and if
it's a Republican pack and Fox News
asking even some questions about Donald
Trump's health you might convince a few
people and we will take it now there are
reports about this ad being
controversial for example this there's
an article this morning in the week
which is called new Lincoln project ad
controversial II questions Trump's
health it's not really controversial if
you've been following this for years and
there's a debate happening in this
article and elsewhere asking whether
Trump's health is fair game now one
argument is listen Trump mocked a
disabled reporter he calls Joe Biden's
sleepy Joe and says Joe Biden doesn't
even know what he's saying he is
regularly implying Joe Biden is
cognitively impaired so that makes
Trump's health fair game I disagree with
that assessment
the reason Trump's health is fair game
is because he's the president and we
have reason to believe that he's lying
about his health his medical report lied
about his height and weight combination
he allegedly coerced the doctor to write
a letter saying Trump would be the
healthiest president in history it's an
empirical claim that no doctor could
actually make so I understand the
concern from disability rights groups
worried that this is bordering on making
fun of health issues that is not what
this is about
this is about understanding the critical
nature of being president and when you
have a president that number one seems
unwell and number two is dishonest about
everything including his height and
weight
we are absolutely right to be concerned
that's really what this is fundamentally
about Donald Trump recently said that
bigotry and Prejudice are going
to leave very easily and quickly from
the United States
just hours after using a racial slur
himself against a sitting Democratic
senator you probably know that Trump has
a long history of claiming that certain
problems are going to be really easy to
fix you might remember that he said
coronavirus was just going to leave in
April it's gonna wash through and leave
like a miracle obviously that didn't
happen
he also said three and a half years ago
that his son-in-law Jared Kushner was
going to very easily and quickly fix the
israeli-palestinian conflict obviously
that has not happened and here is Donald
Trump speaking at a so-called transition
to greatness event saying it himself
bigotry will leave quickly and easily
just hours after he tweeted the slur
pocahontas about senator Elizabeth
Warren here is Donald Trump himself
saying it Americans are good and
virtuous people we have to work together
to confront bigotry and Prejudice
wherever they appear but we'll make no
progress and heal no wounds by falsely
labeling tens of millions of decent
Americans as racist or bigots we have to
get everybody together we have to be in
the same same path I think faster if we
don't do that we have we have problems
and we'll do that we'll do it I think
we're going to do it very easily it'll
go quickly and it'll go you go very
easily so so it's so part of the
solution to bigotry and racism from
seth's is to stop calling people racist
when they say racist things and then
racism will very quickly leave our
country and remember just hours before
Trump said this he tweeted a slur about
Elizabeth Warren where he said quote
seriously failed presidential candidate
senator Elizabeth Pocahontas Warren just
introduced an amendment on the renaming
of many of our legendary military bases
from which we trained to win two world
wars
hopefully our great Republican senators
won't fall for this also relevant to
racism and bigotry is
that Donald Trump was attacking
Elizabeth Warren because she introduced
an amendment looking to rename American
military bases that were named after
pro-slavery Confederate generals
remember the Confederacy was fighting to
preserve states rights for legal slavery
during the American Civil War this is
the same Donald Trump who told four
American Congress women of color to go
back to their countries this is the same
Trump who referred to African countries
as you know what obviously Donald Trump
as we know is in way over his head
and himself is a heavily bigoted
individual but I want to put you in his
shoes for a moment as gross as that
might feel if you don't have any
understanding of bigotry and racism if
you don't understand the history of
bigotry and racism in the United States
as Donald Trump doesn't understand if
you don't understand how long bigotry
and racism have been around in the
United States and how ingrained in the
country they are you might believe that
you could really quickly and easily fix
bigotry and racism in reality what's
going on is that Donald Trump completely
lacks self-awareness and is himself a
huge part of the problem in general when
Trump is wrong about something or makes
a mistake which he never admits to of
course you can usually chalk it up to a
combination of him being what we might
call a bad person like he lacks empathy
completely you can chalk it up to him
being ignorant some would call it stupid
but that's a bit of a pejorative
ignorant maybe is better and/or that
he's delusional in other words he lives
in a fantasy world that includes
delusions of grandeur etc in this case
Trump saying bigotry will leave quickly
and easily it's a lack of empathy for
the problems with bigotry in our country
combined with ignorance about the
history of bigotry and racism in the
United States with the addition of the
delusion he holds that he can fix any
problem it's sort of like the perfect
trifecta now one last thing I know that
some of you lovely right-wingers are
going to write to me or leave a comment
on youtube or tweet me and you're gonna
say David pocahontas isn't a slur
with somebody's name skip it skip I'm
not gonna respond to you I'll tell you
right now Donald Trump is using it as a
slur here to sarcastically referred to
what in her family was an oral history
of Native American ancestry this is sort
of like if you sarcastically or
pejoratively refer to a Jewish person as
slo-mo when [ __ ] is not their name you
would have these same right-wingers
going damage slo-mo is just short for
Salomon it's just a name how is it a
slur the context matters and the context
can make it a slur so please guys right
right wingers put in it is mostly guys
not women don't even bother writing to
me about it okay
in the context Trump used it it was a
slur so Donald Trump delivered a
completely bizarre and
self-congratulatory
and very deranged graduation speech at
West Point over the weekend it was
riddled with failed applause lines but
most notably at one point Donald Trump
visibly struggled to raise a glass of
water to his mouth and later struggled
to walk down a ramp almost having to be
helped down the ramp by a member of the
military now I'm going to show you the
video and we're going to talk about it
but this is as much a story about
right-wing hypocrisy as it is a story
about Donald Trump's cognitive and
physical state if Joe Biden did 20% of
what Trump did at this speech over the
weekend it would be a week of Fox News
and Oh a an adjective I'd and has
dementia with judge Jeanine bringing in
someone whose cousin's girlfriend once
went to medical school to say that Joe
Biden is unfit to lead if this was
Hillary it would be Hillary Parkinson's
times 10 all over again
and yet here they are pretending like
there's just nothing to see here other
than so-called Trump derangement
syndrome and by the way Trump
derangement syndrome is a term that the
right has developed to not have to
address criticisms of Donald Trump you
say something about Trump you have Trump
derangement syndrome it's a way to stop
conversation so first of all at one
point during the speech Donald Trump
goes to drink water picks up a glass
with his right hand brings it about 80%
of the way to his lips his right hand
seemingly could go no higher
he tries moving his mouth
down to bring it down enough to get to
the glass couldn't do it and eventually
uses his left hand to very strangely
pull the glass towards his mouth and
tilted it wasn't clear if the problem
was with Trump's right arm with his
hand-eye coordination we just have no
idea but this is not a normal way to
drink water and it's the second time at
least that we've seen Donald Trump
bizarrely drink water in this way then
the other sort of most notable moment
during the speech was Trump descending
the ramp at the end of the speech very
gingerly carefully like he was about to
fall over very strange and then he took
a sort of hop step at the bottom of the
ramp which he later described as jogging
down the last 10 feet which we'll get to
you'll also notice that the officer
gesturing gesturing for Trump to leave
the stage and then walking next to him
implies that the officer was briefed
ahead of time stay with Trump going down
the ramp so again we've seen Trump come
off of Air Force One sometimes with the
help of an aide we've seen various
versions of this he just doesn't look
stable when he's walking here so is this
the most important thing going on right
now it's not but again if this was Joe
Biden it would be a week on right-wing
media about how this proves Biden simply
cannot be President it's also aggravated
and becomes more interesting by Trump
immediately lying about it Trump
tweeting quote the RAM that I descended
after my West Point commencement speech
was very long and steep now it's not
very steep had no handrail and most
importantly it was very slippery it was
a sunny day it was totally dry the
there's not really any reason why it
would be slippery in people who were
there said it was not slippery and then
Trump saying the last thing I was going
to do is fall for the fake news to have
fun with final ten feet Iran took down
to ground level that's also allied Trump
sort of took a two-step hop he did not
run ten feet so it always attracts more
attention and his worse when Trump
starts lying about it there's also a
tweet for everything with Trump Trump
once criticized Barack Obama for how he
would walk out of Air Force One tweeting
in 2014 that quo
Obama should stop running down the
stairs when getting off Air Force One
doesn't look presidential and at some
point he will take a fall never happened
and by the way we have video of Barack
Obama on the same ramp that Trump was on
Obama certainly looking very very spry
nothing to sneeze at there so this is
all very weird and we don't really have
an explanation which I'll get back to
the speech was also filled with a ton of
really other weird moments Trump at one
point attempting to talk about former
president ulysses s grant he called him
you Lysias a couple of times didn't we
lead we need you to carry on the spirit
of the great general
Alyssia says grant that's weird then
also struggling with the name Douglas
MacArthur seemingly saying MacArthur
MacArthur really just multiple times we
need you to be as bold and determined as
the immortal General Douglas MacArthur
who knew that the American soldier never
ever quits after leaving the Philippines
for Australia at a low point of the
Pacific War in 1942 MacArthur famously
had I shall return and then maybe the
most cringe-worthy moment was Trump's
failed applause line when he mentioned
the two hundred and forty fifth birthday
of the army and paused and looked around
it was complete crickets and then Trump
visit decided to bring up his own
birthday I mean this is real cringe
tomorrow America will celebrate a very
important anniversary the two hundred
and forty fifth birthday of the United
States Army unrelated going to be my
birthday also I don't know if that
happened by accident did that happen by
accident please but it's a great day
because of that army birthday so a
absolutely embarrassing speech now as
far as the medical stuff Trump couldn't
lift a glass of water with his right arm
he seemed when he was walking
that Ram that he was kind of favoring
his left side if someone wanted to
speculate about what's going on in that
there seems to be a left-right issue
here you would start thinking about
stroke remember that he was taken on
short notice to Walter Reed Hospital
that time they lied and said oh we
decided to get a jump on his 20/20
physical that was back in 2019 totally
not believable you start to imagine
because they don't fill in the details
maybe there's something going on here
that could be stroke related now
remember it's speculative we don't know
and the the important thing to remember
is if it were Biden they would be saying
this video is proof that Biden should be
dropping out of the race really really
crazy stuff